the 1986 cult classic fantasy film
Highlander remains one of the most
puzzling pieces of pop culture ever but
what fate has befallen two lucky
performers who got in on the ground
floor and brought this movie to life
here's what the cast of the original
Highlander is up to now back in the 80s
Christopher Lambert looked like the
guide of beef he got his start in a
series of French films before breaking
out in 1980 fleurs Greystoke The Legend
of Tarzan lord of the Apes a whose title
won an immediate place in the hearts of
movie critics who get paid by the word
Lambert's work in Greystoke wound up
landing him the role of Connor MacLeod
in Highlander after director Russell
Mulcahy picture and felt that his eyes
had a quote timeless quality what McKay
didn't know was that some of that might
have come from Lambert's nearsightedness
which made training for the film's sword
fight sequences a challenge
Lambert's on-screen presence has cooled
in the last three decades since
Highlanders release a stint on NCIS Los
Angeles and an appearance in 2011 Ghost
Rider
spirit of Vengeance make up the bulk of
his American work in recent years but
don't worry for him too much as he still
acts regularly in European films and TV
shows in 2016 for example he played
himself in an episode of the French
series call my agent he also showed up
in the 2017 Russian series Mata Hari and
fans of seeing things get boxed and
kicked can check him out as the villain
in 2018 s kickboxer retaliation starring
alongside Lambert was Roxanne Hart who
played McLeod's a modern era love
interest brenda Wyatt a forensic
pathologist tasked with figuring out why
people's heads have been getting chopped
off as often occurs in these situations
brenda falls for Connor when she learns
that the decapitations are a sort of
cultural eccentricity take care of
yourself
dollars hidden part wasn't a huge star
when she was cast in Highlander as she
was mostly known for TV appearances on
80 staples like Remington Steele
nowadays she's still mostly known for
Highlander in the mid 90s she had a 46
episode run on medical drama Chicago
Hope but her film roles have fizzled out
a bit nevertheless she's maintained an
active career with dozens of credits to
her name in the last 10 years she
recently had a multi-episode arc on how
to get away with a murder and appeared
on an episode of the Netflix sitcom
flaked the unofficial spokesman for
Scotland in general masculinity Sean
Connery was by far the biggest celebrity
in the Highlander cast at the time of
the film's released he was already
famous for his turns and Zardoz the man
who would be king and of course Darby
O'Gill and the little people oh and he
also apparently played a spy with the
codename double-oh-seven and several
action flicks Connery's portrayal of a
katana wielding Egyptian immortal was
like much of Highlander puzzling he
appeared in a few more blockbusters in
the following decades but then in 2003
he retired from acting he's since
returned only for voice work first in
the 2005 video game adaptation of From
Russia With Love
amongst Lucasfilm to be playing James
Bond again then he voiced the title
character in the universally maligned
cartoon serve Billy in 2012 which he
seemed to do at least in part because he
was allowed to record his lines in the
Bahamas in recent years he's been a bit
of a reckless which some have speculated
has something to do with his status as a
tax exile when it comes to Clancy Brown
the question isn't so much where is he
now as much as its where isn't he the
towering character actor who went full
maniac as Highlanders Kurgan has stayed
busier than just about anyone in the
cast when Highlander came out he was
still mostly unknown having only
appeared in a handful of movies
including the cult classic The
Adventures of Buckaroo Banzai across the
8th dimension he'd also rounded out his
classical dramatic training with an
episode of The Dukes of Hazzard but
Highlander was his first major gig
according to Russell Mulcahy on was so
nervous during his fight scene with Sean
Connery that he accidentally smashed the
flat side of his sword into a table this
shattered the weapon and sent a short of
it flying past Connery's head thus
convincing Connery to use his stunt
double a little more often since then
Browne has been working pretty much
non-stop his face should be recognizable
to fans of The Shawshank Redemption and
Starship Troopers among other things but
perhaps the most beloved role of his
entire career is a voice only one as
he's played mr. Krabs in hundreds of
episodes of Spongebob Squarepants and in
2019 he made a big splash in the Star
Wars universe as berg in an episode of
the mandalorian the death of Heather
Connor MacLeod first wife served two
important purposes in Highlander first
if foreshadowed the lonely life that
Connor had in store for him as an
immortal doomed to watch those he cared
about succumbed to sickness and death
second it gave Queens Brian May an
excuse to write the song who wants to
live forever which he has said was
inspired by an early cut of the film
Heather was played by English actress BD
Edney another newcomer at the time of
filming she never broke out
internationally the way some of her cast
mates did nevertheless she's maintained
a steady stage and TV career in the
United Kingdom her most notable recent
credit is the historical drama series
Poldark which tells the story of a
British soldier returning home after the
American Revolution check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
or coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]